تقرير جديد مذهل من ABC News
يثير مخاوف خطيرة للغاية بشأن
تعامل دونالد ترامب مع معلومات
الأمن القومي الأمريكي الحساسة للغاية
وفقًا لـ ABC، حيث
يُزعم أن الرئيس السابق شارك بيانات حول
أسطول الغواصات النووية في البلاد
مع عضو أجنبي في نادي Lago الخاص به
في أبريل  في عام 2021، زُعم أن هذا العضو
الملياردير الأسترالي
ناقش
المعلومات السرية للغاية مع أكثر من اثني
عشر شخصًا آخر، بما في ذلك أعضاء
رسميون أجانب وصحفيون، وبحسب ما ورد تم إبلاغ
محققي المستشار الخاص جاك سميث
بالمحادثة المزعومة
ولكن حتى الآن لم
يتم تضمينها في  لائحة الاتهام ضد
ترامب لسنا على علم بأي رد
من ترامب أو عضو نادي مارالاجو
لقناة ABC الإخبارية مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار أه
حقيقة هذا تقرير إعلامي مصدر واحد
وحقيقة أن المجلس الخاص
اختار عدم استخدامه لأي سبب كان
في لائحة اتهام مع تلك
التحذيرات أه في الاعتبار أه هذا حقا
بالنسبة لي
مخالفة خطيرة أه وهو للأسف
جزء طويل من آخر في سلسلة طويلة من
انتهاكات أه أمننا القومي
من خلال الفشل في الحماية لحماية
هذه الحواس بشكل صحيح  من المعلومات إذا كان هذا
يتضمن إطلاق صواريخ باليستية من البحر
أه والغواصات التي تحملها،
فهذا جزء من
ترسانتنا الاستراتيجية الوطنية التي تصل إلى
جوهر بقاء الأمة لذا
فمن الصعب المبالغة في تقدير ما إذا كان هذا صحيحًا
من الصعب المبالغة في تقديره كيف  جدية هذا من خلال
تأكيد أه المعرفة بأه هذه
الغواصات مع أجانب
وبحسب تقرير ABC ما يصل إلى 45 شخصًا
كانوا على علم بهذا ربما أكثر لذلك
هذا بالنسبة لي أه خطير للغاية إذا
كان في الواقع
صحيح